this all looks so delectable how does
anyone choose ah carefully sir there's
some exquisite new choices in the 23.2
menu I definitely recommend the
day/night theme from Africa interesting
do you how do you think that's like
fresh like fresh fresh I think we might
have something for you if you're looking
for totally new features or important
improvements version 23.2 of the android
support library doesn't disappoint
there's two new additions to the support
library family support vector drawable
and support animated vector drawable
these bring the power and flexibility of
vector drawables to all API 7 and higher
devices and animated vector drawables to
all api 11 and higher devices
I expect smaller apks from you as you
all replace multiple PNG assets with a
single vector drawable app compat is
already taking advantage of vector
drawables in this release save everyone
some space and it provides a handy
source compatible for image views and
image buttons making it easy to use your
new vector drawables check out our blog
post for all the details on how this
works now that's not all the change with
app compat though in addition to the
current theme app compat and themed
acrobat light there's a new theme app
compat day/night themes specifically for
API 14 and higher devices now making a
UI that adapts the time of day just
means picking the right theme and
testing thoroughly you'll be able to
manually change between day and night of
app level or activity level with new
methods in app compat delegate perfect
for testing or even as a setting you
exposed to your users another new
feature in 23.2 is the addition to the
android design support library bottom
sheets
now this coordinator later behavior
attaches to any view allows you to drag
it open and closed peek or hide
completely there's even a bottom sheet
dialog and bottom sheet dialog fragment
for easily styling a dialogue as a
bottom sheet magical now if you have a
media playing app you'll be happy to
know this release also includes Media
Browser servers compact and media
browser combat allowing you to use
previously only lollipop and higher
api's all the way back to API for
whether you're looking for an easy way
to connect your media playback service
to your UI or looking to integrate with
Android auto and Android wear this is
the API to look into of course there's
another Android out there Android TV the
Leanback sport library's guided step
fragment which lets you guide users
through a series of steps has received a
number of enhancements the blog has all
the details if that's your thing as well
as information on all the other new
features in version 23.2 so have you
made your selection thank you there's
actually only one person who's made it
through that ordeal